consternación en búfalo por una matanza
en un supermercado que ha tenido lugar
en un barrio de mayoría afroamericana
eso demuestra los objetivos de un
sospechoso que además tenía toda una
trayectoria en internet y es por eso que
hemos escuchado palabras de la
gobernadora del estado de nueva york-
del alcalde de buffalo contundentes no
sólo con el tema de las armas un
problema endémico en eeuu por que
repetidas veces tenemos que
lamentablemente informar de este tipo de
matanzas de terrorismo doméstico pero
está motivado en este caso por una
cuestión racial por una cuestión de
supremacía blanca que en internet se
alienta y es por eso que los oficiales
electos han hecho mucha insistencia en
las necesidades de trabajar en
legislaciones que permitan que esto no
vuelva a suceder